E aí
[Aplausos]
e qual o impacto você quer deixar no
mundo já se perguntou isso essa pode ser
uma pergunta um pouco de confortável mas
ela desconforto que nascem as grandes
soluções as grandes transformações que a
gente precisa a gente não veio nesse
mundo para ficar sentado no sofá
confortável com a boca escancarada cheia
de dentes esperando a morte chegar a
gente veio para transformar para se
transformar e para contribuir com a
construção de um mundo melhor do mundo
que a gente acredita e quando a gente
fala de impacto social de impacto
Launcher é preciso ter muita coragem
para encarar a verdade para encarar a
luz e sombra tá Qual a psicanálise de
tudo que a gente faz de tudo que a gente
escolhe sejamos nós pessoas físicas ou
jurídicas a condene do coronavírus
trouxe uma série de transformações para
as nossas vidas e a gente já sabe trouxe
um monte de novos termos com os quais a
gente convive diariamente como mortos
leitos vacina sequelas e também trouxe
outros ações sociais o alimento sgq uma
siglas chique e que nada mais é do que
tudo que a sustentabilidade sempre
tentou criar no segundo setores
econômicos todos e que agora o mercado
financeiro se apropriou e a gente está
passando a conviver com esta sigla que é
em várias mental soushuuhen governantes
em inglês mas o que essa moda né que é
uma moda a gente pode dizer eu desejo
Reze todos os dias para que ela não
fique apenas sendo moda a gente precisa
entender que é que isso de fato muda o
que é que isso de fato traz para a gente
em termos reais mas o que falar sobre
Impacto é importante entender também o
que é o impacto no seu conceito mais
profundo precisamos trazer um novo olhar
um pouco menos ovos eu sobre tudo isso
falar de impacto positivo de
sustentabilidade de empresas socialmente
responsáveis não é só sobre falar não é
sobre a aparentar é sobre ser é sobre
ter evidências as grandes transformações
sociais que nós precisamos elas não são
feitas e elas são feitas de dados de
realidade de indicadores de pessoas de
história de vida de números de tudo
aquilo que é palpável e material e que a
gente precisa de fato considerada como
nós estamos falando de impacto social e
aí a gente precisa lembrar sempre do que
aqui é esse conceito Impact was sem
Impacto Achei um conceito que nasceu
derivado de outro expressão também
inglês que é um bluemotion que foi muito
utilizada para classificar as práticas
das empresas que mostravam suas
campanhas ambientais mas que na prática
não tinham compromissos ambientais
sólidos profundos e verdadeiros ou seja
era apenas um ótima lavagem uma
maquiagem esse termo emoji de origem a
outro tem um tempo pacto Launcher e
outros também como diversos washing
Black Washington washingt que vão nessa
mesma linha daquilo que aparenta ser mas
não é isso não é amor isso é cilada
então importante perceber também de que
maneira esses e chegam para gente e a
gente a gente às vezes aceita ser
minimamente questionar quando a gente
fala de impacto social de impacto a
gente já estão de Pato negócio de
impacto a primeira pergunta que
precisamos fazer é para quem vai esse
Impacto quem é o dono desse Impacto e
essa Impacto ele fica para quem se for
só para nós mesmos para as nossas
empresas para os nossos projetos
negócios negócios está errado Impacto
social é sobre aquilo que eu deixo esse
eu deixo eu preciso que alguém queira
receber quantas vezes desenvolver
desenvolvemos campanhas e projetos sem
minimamente perguntará outro se ele quer
receber esse aqui é uma solução tão
mirabolante maravilhosa que nós estamos
desenvolvendo ela atende ao que o outro
de fato precisa eu queria contar uma
história para vocês a muitos anos atrás
eu trabalho em um projeto na Chapada
Diamantina e que uma das suas ela leva
energia elétrica para essa comunidade
que uma o centro de Quilombo chamada
Vale do Pati e a ideia leva energia
elétrica para eles e eu fui fazer um
trabalho de escuta com essa comunidade e
é chegando lá a gente apresentou o plano
e uma das famílias disse assim para mim
né ninguém quer energia elétrica aqui
nós somos felizes sem energia elétrica a
energia elétrica afasta as pessoas Aliás
só queremos energia elétrica para
assistir aos jogos do Brasil e é
obviamente essa comunidade hoje tem
energia elétrica mas aquilo me marcou
porque é de fato o que é solução para o
outro para que recebem não é uma
prioridade Impacto social entender Qual
é o caminho que ameaçam percorre-se
aquela campanha se aquele projetos
aquele negócio de impacto de fato
resolve o problema para quem vive afinal
de contas nós temos uma mania uma
tendência não muito saudável de achar
que os problemas os outros os problemas
do o que vemos são simples de serem
resolvidos é igual Instagram como
parecem felizes as pessoas que nós não
conhecemos na vida real se Nós pensamos
pensarmos negócios de impacto positivo
em projetos de impacto social Positivo
sem repensar a forma como eles são
feitos EA forma como eles inclui essas
pessoas ditas beneficiários nós
estaremos reproduzindo a mesma lógica de
poder que nós já conhecemos e que nós já
sabemos que não funcionam uma lógica
verticalizada uma lógica centralizadora
uma lógica pautada em Privilégio de
alguns grupos sobre os outros se a gente
está comprometi a gente está
comprometido verdadeiramente em
construir novas formas de negócios e
novos modelos produtivos a importante
também pensar a nova forma de decidir
sobre eles novas formas de incluir
pessoas nova forma novas formas de
gestar essas pessoas dentro desse
negócio senão a gente vai tá fazendo
control c control V tá pegando as mesmas
fórmulas prontas Mantendo as mesmas
estruturas de poder as quais dizemos
combater que quase sempre se concentram
as decisões e o poder seja ele
intelectual financeiro nas mãos dos
mesmos quase sempre homens quase sempre
homens brancos eurocêntricos
heteronormativos se quase sempre
católicos se a gente é de fato está
comprometida gerar Impacto social na
base transformar as estruturas sociais
que nós precisamos transformar não era a
mente adornos para soluções é
superficiais nós precisamos repensar a
forma como nós desenvolvemos as empresas
e também projetos sociais Se nós
queremos de fato entender que Impacto
não é somente sobre a ponta mas a sobre
a forma como eu faço como eu gerencio
como eu produzo e como eu crio esse
Impacto nós precisamos abrir a casa nós
precisa a casca do nosso ego para
permitir que outras pessoas façam parte
é preciso abrir o palco é preciso
entender que o nosso palco ele é grande
e nele deve caber muitas pessoas todo
mundo pode brilhar como diria Caetano
gente é pra brilhar e não é para morrer
de fome e como a gente vai pensar por
exemplo a solução da fome discutindo as
soluções com quem nunca sentiu fome é
importante que projetos sociais que
negócio de impacto que as empresas
quando pensam suas ações de impacto
inclui um pessoas que vivem sim
problemas do contrário a gente tá
tirando conhecimento sendo a mesma
estrutura de poder através desse
conhecimento e esse conhecimento ele não
movimenta a roda a partir de quem
precisa movimentar a roda mas o que
empresas com propósito empresas com a
alma nós precisamos de empresas que
tenham compromisso com seus impactos que
conhece são seus impactos negativos que
aceitem esses impactos para que eles
possam ser transformados igual a gente
faz com a gente na terapia eu quero
aceito reconheço para depois transformar
ninguém cura a ferida que não aceita
isso vale para gente quando sociedade a
gente vai isso vale para as empresas e
governos é importante que nós olhamos
para os impactos com muita coragem com
muita verdade e com muito compromisso de
fazer de toda a cadeia produtiva que
está em torno de nós com todas as partes
interessadas engajadas um processo de
construção contínua e um processo de
fato de inovação inovação não é sobre
tecnologia inovação é sobre pessoas
sobre novas soluções e é muito injusto
conceder as pessoas subgrupos
sub-representados as pessoas que estão
as comunidades mais vulneráveis apenas o
lugar de coadjuvante ou apenas um lugar
de beneficiaram é muito justo com ela
sabe porque porque essas pessoas fazem
do seu cotidiano O Milagre Diário da
sobrevivência e com salário mínimo vendo
com condições insalubres essas pessoas
sabem todos os dias sobre inovação ela
sabe mais o que nós ela sabe mais do que
as pessoas que ficam atrás da mesa
desenvolvendo aplicativos ou escrevendo
políticas públicas sobre realidades que
nunca foram sequer vistas ouvidas à
escuta no processo de gestão de impacto
é fundamental
se a gente quer construir de fato
futuros possíveis melhores mais justos
mais bonitos é preciso incluir é preciso
fazer mais dizer - eu não tenho todas as
respostas por isso não sei não existem
fórmulas prontas Mas uma coisa eu tenho
certeza a gente vai descobrir junto
junto é a única forma de ir junto a
única forma de entender o impacto
positivo que eu quero gerar de fato ele
transforma aquilo que eu preciso
transformar em termos de sociedade para
Além de Mim Impacto social o negócio de
impacto e-social tem satisfazer a quem
recebe número a mente o meu web de achar
que eu estou sendo mais evoluída porque
desenvolver um negócio de impacto não é
sobre isso Impacto social positivo não é
sobre fazer em patchwork em não é sobre
lavagem é sobre construção é sobre fazer
junto e eu tenho certeza de que no dia
que a gente conseguir aí vai ser bom
porque só é bom mesmo quando for bom
para todo mundo
E aí